depuis le 1er novembre les théâtres
s'organisent pour ouvrir leurs portes
aux compagnies pour filmer les
spectacles ou être vu par des
professionnels au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines 15 spectacles
ont été maintenus dans ces conditions
objectif que les spectacles soient vues
entre le mois de novembre et aujourd'hui
il ya des 10es lady diana jaillir des
centaines de spectacles qui ont été
créés beaucoup l'on va plus jouer
c'est dans ce cadre que la compagnie les
filles du renard pâle a présenté son
spectacle résiste une représentation
destinée aux professionnels et aux
programmateurs le spectacle de
funambules était à l'origine conçu pour
l'extérieur
la compagnie a c'est toute la semaine le
théâtre pour adapter ce spectacle pour
la salle puisque ni les lumières ni
leçon nous sont exactement le même qu'à
l'extérieur on est vraiment dans des
conditions de jeu très différentes donc
voilà ça fait partie des choses que l'on
arrive à faire pendant ce à dire ce
confinement mais pendant cette fermeture
des théâtres sur scène un régisseur une
chanteuse et une funambule cette
dernière évolue sur une structure conçue
spécialement pour le spectacle
il a appelé le fil instable donc l'idée
c'est un fils qui se casse la gueule qui
s'incline qui bouge qui va dans tous les
sens l'idée c'est de tenir sur le fil
coûte que coûte que coûte quoi qu'il
arrive et de voilà de faire passer aussi
le message de quoi qu'il arrive même si
une fille l'iton vie voilà qu'il ya
plein de choses qui se passent à 20,2 de
finalement se réapproprier l'espace tel
qu'il est devenu et puis tout ce qui
peut nous arriver dans la gueule bah
finalement en retirer quelque chose de
positif et puis continuer à se battre
continue à aller de l'avant pendant le
spectacle le fil s'élèvera à 4 m 85 une
petite hauteur pour joel klein et il est
pas très au delà il ya pas mal de
techniques donc moi je reste que sur le
fil n'y a pas de plateforme votre façon
à structure ya pas de plate forme il n'y
a rien donc je suis de az que sur le fil
ou sur le balancier et sinon après je
faisais dans les grandes traversées je
peux monter pour l'instant que les
fesses et jusqu'à 40 mètres de hauteur
et puis sur des grandes longueurs de 120
mètres de long ou plus la compagnie
reviendra à saint quentin en yvelines en
septembre pour retrouver son public
elle présentera une version rue du
spectacle